-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with Tariq Trotter
from the Roots,
and we are about to play
charades!
But first we're going to
need some partners.
Joining Tariq's team, he stars
in "Purlie Victorious:
A Non-Confederate Romp
Through the Cotton Patch."
Now on Broadway.
It's Leslie Odom Jr.!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
-Come on.
-That's what I'm talk--
That's what I'm talking --
That's what I'm talking about.
Come on.
-Taking you down.
-Yeah.
-Joining my team,
You can see her
on "Saturday Night Live"
this weekend
with host Pete Davidson.
Please welcome Chloe Fineman!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice...
-Yeah.
-That's teamwork.
-Uh-huh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on. Come on.
-Happy to see you.
-Now, you all know
how to play charades.
We're gonna do four rounds.
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
And then the fifth round
is the showdown.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
I will go first. You can all
take your seats.
Chloe, you can sit here.
-Team Jimmy. Here we go.
-Yeah, that's us, buddy.
-Okay.
-Alright.
What number shall I choose?
-Six!
-Wow. Just one guy yelled out.
"Five? Five. Maybe six."
-Okay.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Alright.
-Hm.
Okay.
Hm.
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay. Ready?
-Yeah.
It's a song.
Okay. One word.
Rain.
"I Can't Stand the Rain"?
No. "Rain Falling Down."
"It's Raining Men."
♪ Running in the rain ♪
♪ Running ♪
No running. No.
Fast.
Storm! Storm!
-Um...
-Faucet.
Washing your hands.
Water. Waterfall?
-Yes!
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Doing the slalom!
-Don't go chasin'.
Don't go chasin'.
-I get a little slalom
there, yeah.
A rare dance.
I never pull that one out.
-Chasing waterfalls.
-I was chasing waterfalls.
-Wow.
-Nice.
-Hard.
-Am I up?
-Gosh. I almost had
a heart attack.
Yes, Tariq, you're up.
-Come on. Come on.
-That was great, partner.
-Whew.
-What are we doing?
-Five! Five or six!
[ Audience shouting ]
Five or six!
-No. I'm locked in. Come on.
-Ohh!
-Okay. I'm locked in.
-Alright. Let's go.
-He is. Look. He's focused.
-It's a song.
"Thriller."
Oh.
Monsters. Monster.
"Monster Mash."
Come on. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
-You didn't even say
"two words." Nothing.
-Come on.
-It's charades, bro.
You're not supposed
to say anything.
-I know, but you can act it out.
-He didn't need
that information.
-It's Philly. We got a thing.
-That's a Philly thing?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-What -- By the way,
what monster were you doing?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey. The scariest one.
-Right.
I don't know that --
I don't know that movie at all.
-Okay.
-Chloe.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Four? Two?
[ Laughter ]
-Seven!
-Oh! Okay. Um...
-It's a movie.
-Yeah.
-Hi. Hello. Hi, there.
Ooh! Robot.
-"Barbie!"
-"Barbie."
Wow.
-Ohh.
Someone yelled out, "Barbie."
-Why'd you help?!
-They helped -- That's --
You can't do that.
-I don't know how it works.
Yeah.
-What do you mean,
you don't know how it works?
I thought of it, too.
-That was pretty good.
-Yeah.
-That was pretty --
Okay. I need a little help.
-That was great. I guessed it.
-Seven!
-Seven. I heard seven.
-Five or six!
-Oh, damn. Okay.
-No, no. No, no.
Come on. Come on.
-Okay.
-That's so funny.
-Alright. Alright. Alright.
Okay.
-It's a TV show.
Three words.
Three or four words.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Good luck.
-Ooh.
-"Too Close for Comfort."
"Goofy."
"Dumb & Dumber."
[ Laughter ]
"Jackass." Head.
"Bottoms Up."
Um, um...
"Gopher." Uh, uh...
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, whoa!
-Ohh!
-Is it "Wayne's World"? No, no.
-"Beavis and Butt-Head"?
-"Beavis and Butt..." Oh!
-Yeah.
I would have never got that.
-I got it. I got what...
-Yeah, yeah.
-I was trying to work --
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I should've --
Cause he's a Butt-Head.
And I get it.
-Yeah.
-No, I was -- I was Beavis.
I was Beavis.
Hey, guys.
This is the final round, okay?
So now we're going to choose
one person from each team.
We're both gonna draw
the same clue at the same time.
If the partners get it,
they win 10,000 points,
win the whole game.
-Okay.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Chloe, you and Leslie.
-Oh [bleep].
-Okay.
-Shooby dooby doo!
-Come on, Purlie.
-Come on, now!
-Okay. Which one?
Which one are we drawing?
[ Audience shouting ]
-They all said, "Five."
-Aah! Okay.
Okay.
-Oh [bleep]. Okay. Okay.
-Okay. Ready?
-Yep. Go. Movie.
Snort. Cocaine.
-[Simultaneously]
"Cocaine Bear"!
[ Bell dinging ]
♪♪
-I said "Cocaine Bear"!
I said "Cocaine Bear"!
-No!
-I said "Cocaine Bear"!
I said "Cocaine Bear"!
I said it first!
"Cocaine Bear."
No. You -- No way.
-Go back to the tape.
-We got to check the tape.
We got to check the tape.
-Movie. Snort. Cocaine.
-[Simultaneously]
"Cocaine Bear"!
[ Bell dinging ]
-You said -- No, you said,
"C-C-C-C-C-C-C-C..."
No. I said, "Cocaine Bear"!
-I actually said --
-"C-C-C-C-C-C-C..."
-I don't know, man.
I said, "Cocaine Bear"!
Said the actual title
of the movie.
The judges have awarded me
with all the money.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
My thanks --
-Congrats. Congrats.
-My thanks to Leslie Odom Jr.
Chloe Fineman!
Tariq Trotter right there.
We're talking to --
We're talking to Leslie
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.